we all want to have a good stable
relationship with somebody and one of
the problems with early-stage intense
feelings of romantic love is that it's
part of the oldest parts of the brain
that become activated brain regions
linked with drive with craving with
obsession with motivation and in fact
some cognitive regions up in the
prefrontal cortex that have evolved much
more recently begin to shut down brain
regions linked with this decision-making
planning ahead you know people were
madly in love can fall madly in love
with somebody who's married who lives on
the other side of the planet who comes
from a different religion and somehow
they'll say to themselves we'll work it
out we can work this out because of all
that energy of intense romantic love and
also the shutting down of various brain
systems linked with decision-making so
one of the things that I say to people
is you know before you decide to marry
somebody spend some a good deal of time
with them so that some of that early
stage intense feelings of romantic love
can begin to subside and you can begin
to really see what you've got
as a matter of fact I'm very optimistic
about the future of relationships
because we're spending so much time now
getting to know somebody before we Wed
you know great many people are having
these one-night stands and friends with
benefits and living together before they
marry and there was a recent study in
which they asked a lot of single people
who were living together with somebody
why have they not yet married and 67
percent were terrified of divorce
terrified of the not only the legal and
the financial and the economic but the
personal and social fallout of divorce
and so began I began to realize maybe
all this hooking up and friends with
benefits and living together is not
recklessness
maybe it's caution maybe singles are
trying to learn every single thing they
can about a potential partner before
they tie the knot and in short marriage
used to be the beginning of a relation
now it's the finale and I think that
that is very positive as a matter of
fact I work with match.com I'm their
senior they're their chief scientific
adviser and we did a study of married
people not on the site match.com of
course of 1,100 married people and I had
reason well if there's this long
pre-commitment stage of getting to know
somebody maybe by the time you walk down
the aisle you know what you've got
you're happy with what you've got
and you're going to build a long stable
really happy marriage maybe we're going
towards a time of happier marriages
because relationships can end before you
tie the knot so within this study I
asked these 1,100 married people a lot
of questions but one of the questions
was would you remarry the person you're
currently married to and 81 percent said
yes and I think that with what I call
fast sex slow love with this slow love
process of getting to know somebody very
carefully over a long period of time
it's going to help the brain readjust
some of these brain regions for decision
making you're going to get to know how
this person handles your parents at
Christmas or whatever holiday and you
know how they handle your friends how
they handle their money and how they
handle an argument how they handle
getting exercise in their own health and
your health etc you learn a lot about
the person I think we're in a fair I'm
very optimistic about the future because
of this concept of slow love I'm not
really in the advice business or this
should business I think people should
marry when they feel like marrying but
from what I know about the brain if it
were me I'd wait at least two years
because in two years you see the full
cycle of the Year twice you see how they
handle Halloween how they handle
Christmas or Hanukkah how they handle
you know summer fun and to see that see
that twice is I think important and by
the way you can sustain that intense
feeling of romantic love for two years
I've studied 5,000 people through match
not on the match.com site a
representative sample of Americans based
on the US Census and a great many of
them say that they've had the experience
of sustained feelings of intense
romantic love for somebody for two to
five years so if you pick the right
person and you know how to sustain some
of the joy I think you can create a
long-term attachment that is full also
of periods of romantic love we all want
to sustain a long-term happy partnership
and psychologists will give you a long
list of smart ways to sustain it but I'd
like to say what the brain can add I
studied the brain and the first thing
that you want to do is sustain the three
basic brain systems for mating and
reproduction sex drive have sex with the
partner have sex regularly with the
partner if you don't have time schedule
the time to have sex with the partner
because when you have sex with a partner
you're driving up the testosterone
system so you're going to want to have
more sex but you also have all the
cuddling which is going to drive up the
oxytocin system and give you feelings of
attachment and having sex with the
person any kind of stimulation of the
genitals drives up the dopamine system
and can sustain feelings of romantic
love so basically having said and of
course there can be good jokes about it
and relaxation about it
that is good for the body and the mind
so have sex with the person and sustain
that brain system of the sex drive to
sustain feelings of intense romantic
love do novel things together novelty
drives up the dopamine system and can
sustain feelings of romantic love and
this isn't just in the bedroom just go
to a different restaurant on Friday
night take your bicycle instead of a car
read to each other in bed sit together
on the couch and and have a discussion
about something new read new books
together novelty novelty novelty
sustains feelings of intense romantic
love you also want to sustain feelings
of deep attachment and to do that you
have to just stay in touch learn to
sleep in the person's arm at least start
that way cuddle after dinner walk
arm-in-arm down
the street hold hands together now put
your foot on top of his foot or her foot
while you're having dinner and gently of
course but stay in touch that drives up
the oxytocin system and can give you
feelings of deep attachment to the
partner so you want to sustain all three
of those brain systems sex drive
feelings of romantic love and feelings
of deep attachment but we've also found
out what's going on in the brain in
long-term happy partners we did a study
a brain scanning study of people who
were married an average of 21 years and
those people who were married in average
of 21 years who were still madly in love
with their partner showed activity in
three brain regions a brain region
linked with empathy a brain region
linked with controlling your own
emotions and a brain region linked with
what we call positive illusions the
simple ability but sometimes hard to
overlook what you don't like about
somebody and then focus on what you do
so last but not least we've now known
that if you say several nice things to
your partner every day I would suggest
five but if you can only pull off two or
three whatever say nice things to your
partner that actually reduces their
cholesterol reduces their cortisol which
is the stress hormone and boost their
immune system but it also boosts yours
so what the brain says about a happy
long-term partnership is overlooked what
you don't like and focus on what you do
be happy express empathy for the partner
control your own emotions have sex with
the partner do novel things together
stay in touch and say several nice
things every day and you will your brain
will help you sustain a long-term deep
attachment we're built to we're built to
love
you